una propuesta impulsada por la izquierda
pero que deja a la derecha en una
posición favorable los resultados de las
elecciones celebradas en Chile el
domingo marcaron la superioridad de los
conservadores un escenario opuesto al de
los comicios anteriores el partido
republicano se quedó con 23 de los 50
escaños disponibles 7 más que la facción
oficialista unidad para Chile Si se
juntan con la derecha de chile seguro
podrían decir la confección de la
Constitución sin pactar con los
izquierdistas el presidente Gabriel
borich felicitó a los ganadores pero les
pidió mesura el nombre del estado y el
pueblo
de chile les
invito templanza el proceso anterior
y debemos decirlo
fracasó entre otras cosas porque no
supimos escucharnos entre quienes
pensábamos distinto Franz 24 diálogo con
Néstor Aburto director de contenidos de
radio bío-bío que me explicó el panorama
que enfrentará el país trasandino se va
a alinear esta derecha en el consejo
constitucional que parte el próximo seis
de junio con la derecha tradicional es
una de las grandes dudas porque
eventualmente podría existir una
posibilidad de que la derecha
tradicional pudiera pactar con algunos
sectores de la centro izquierda que son
pocos pero que podrían pactar y hacer un
solo bloque eso es lo que está en juego
a contar de las próximas semanas los 50
miembros del Consejo Constituyente
confeccionarán una nueva propuesta de
Constitución para el domingo 17 de
diciembre fecha en la que se votará un
plebiscito de salida donde la ciudadanía
decidirá se aprueba o rechaza el cambio